yeah I was just nicely drifting
upper-left minding my own business then
this guy gets quickscoped
I won't like it felt good and his brain
was left on the floor why hello there
welcome to Playstation grenade it's time
for more Saturday shenanigans but this
time it's a little different this week
I have been to America and it was bloody
awesome over in Los Angeles for the
gameplay reveal of Borderlands 3 and
it's a freaking awesome game so I
thought we'd go through some of the
clips that I recorded whilst I was there
and I'll tell you about my experiences
and what I think to the game so anyway
if you're interested
this is Borderlands 3 and I absolutely
love it so this is about 20 minutes in
maybe a little bit less than that I'm
just getting used to how switching guns
works and inventory and things like that
and I've met this young lady who's
British and not a bad guy
well not yet anyway yeah I've got a
thing for looking for Easter eggs I need
to stop doing that but she takes cover
here I was thinking why you taking cover
love and then I realizes loads there and
I thought come on let's get involved
darling let's get involved so that Naida
throughout spawns more grenades if it
hits so look at that
it's a flaming bloodbath that's just
from one Nate I don't have a thing for
this pistol it really is addicting to
use
[Music]
so the AI wasn't extremely intelligent
but I think that's really because we
wanted to feel like badasses for our
first ever use of the game so I think I
switched to my sniper soon which I
haven't used before
oh the barrel there it blows up now it's
like an ice frost barrel so you can
stack up on different energy types so
this is radiation that sniper rifle it
charges up so you have to aim it's not
for quick Scopus you have to aim charge
up the bullet and then let it rip and
look at that absolutely rinse that
fellow
oh I hit a glitch here sorry I'm
actually talking to the dev next to me
saying that there was some sort of
invisible wall that was stopping me
there and I'm sure that's gone in the
final version so the heavy gunner his
weak spot is that thing on his back he
be gone he be gone so one thing I
noticed quite quickly is how quick you
can switch from weapon to weapon in
Borderlands 3 yeah I tried to switch
weapon with l1 I didn't go
oh and if you see any button prompts
they are Xbox button prompts because
this event was sponsored by Xbox so I
have to use an Xbox controller and as a
PlayStation 4 player it was down
difficult to get used to it's an awesome
putt though get me wrong I really like
the controller but if you're not used to
using it down it takes time and when you
see X prompts on screen and you press
the wrong button it's quite annoying too
yeah I try to flank just back then to
see if the AI would track me and they do
but they aren't particularly good at
aiming the AI but again I think that's a
balancing issue they want us to feel
like we could wreck anyone Oh increase
the guns do so much damage well of
course at the right level but it feels
heavy feels like they're doing something
it isn't like what the divisions used to
feel like where you'd put thousands of
bullets into someone and and it wouldn't
even scratch them even even if they are
body sponges on this that there's
animations feel like there's weight
behind each bullets I absolutely get
rinsed there into my own grenade look at
this I don't feel so good mr. stark pyro
Tex boom Shakalaka
yeah the ultras The Ultimates The
Specials whatever you want to call them
they are so much fun to use
in fact I'll show you all of them I
played as two different characters of
the book that we could play us a Mara
who's a siren and Fergie sane yet Zayn
and he's basically an amalgam of all the
other characters from previous games but
I'll talk about him when we get there
look at the size of the map there's so
much to cover and this is just Promethea
there's going to be multiple planets to
go to anyway I'll shut up with a little
help
I've got hang about what is that thing
on your face I'm a vault hunter and I'm
here with the Crimson Raiders depends do
count my biceps separately they're good
Rhys really good and we need all the
help we can get bandits are pouring into
the city and they're working with mallow
on looks like Katt Seagal was made a
deal with the Calypso's top agent is
gearing up to strike in Matawan
strategic yoga mind yeah so he said Giga
minds so that's the boss that we're
going to try and track down in this
gameplay demo right while you go
mitrice's agent I'm gonna get this base
back online and start securing more of
the city Oh before you head off I've got
something for you right I've got a bit
of a thing for Lorelei because we don't
really get many British heroes in films
or games they always tend to be the bad
guys
since you're heading downtown I'm
hooking you up with a cyclone it's fast
and light perfect forgetting about the
city's
take it for a spin cheers darling will
do yes I do make my vehicle's pink you
know me you know me well so I'm pushing
forward to find try and find this
Megamind thing and I just like this
radiation sniper one hit on something
that's humanoid just look at them they
absolutely evaporate but it also does
decent damage against other things if
you can hit your crits which i think i
tried to do here yeah there we go there
we go and like it expecting most of
these types of games that how long it
takes to reload is part of of managing
your inventory part of figuring out what
you're going to do and yeah that the
strongest weapons tend to have quite
long reload times whereas do like these
weapons like I have now is like less
than a second and you've got another
four bullets I really wish this weapon
had eight bullets but we can also I
didn't see it firsthand but we can also
upgrade so we can go to Marcus on the
sanctuary 3 the ship that we're going to
live on and we can upgrade enough sure
we can upgrade enough to have more
bullets or we carry more bullets so we
can adapt as we as we go on of course
there are also vault hunters from the
previous games WTF
[Music]
and they have these little pop-up
screens
I love these ironically does a lot of
dividing and his name's zero yeah it's a
bloody brilliant okay boss fight time so
this time I've switched to the
characters Zayn so this is Megamind and
the reason I switched to Zayn is because
I played this three times to get one
weapon which only has a potential chance
of dropping so this is the third third
time I fought Giga mind to get this
weapon at the end I'll show you very
soon okay so Zayn has got a couple of
abilities he can leave behind a sort of
a fake version of himself which also
attacks and we can switch to it whenever
we like so it's like having a second
person on the battlefield with you so if
you want damage output that's a really
really good character to choose and he
he also has that drone flying around cuz
he can have two abilities going at the
same time so he is quite opie and not
sure how they're going to to balance
that out but as a first choice he's a
great one to go for Zayn and he's Irish
and who the hell doesn't love an Irish
accent so we're almost through shield
we're getting there slowly but surely
and in three second bomb right hand
corner two seconds one second we have
the first ability back so we can get our
decoy out and go on flank and hopefully
he will get the attention of the boss
and we can start quitting him on his
back and here's another weapon which
needs to be charged but when it lands it
does damage over time which is very
useful and just when our decoy is about
to end we should have our drone back
again so yeah Zen is so opie it's done
good and it always finishes with just
loot galore
a waterfall of blue look at all this
stuff yeah I spent a good 10 minutes
looking through all this stuff but the
thing I wanted was bright gold here it
is look at that bad boy
so this is the smart gun XXL and there's
also the exceptional body maker
something like that and there's the
brain we came for so I didn't get to use
it a lot but when you reload you throw
the gun out and look it's a little brain
on legs and I do have some footage not
much but I have some footage if it hits
the target and explodes with corrosive
damage if it doesn't it goes to the
ground oh man I love that just scurries
off so good there's loads of guns no
they're just this good this one when I
throw it out it just sticks to walls so
I do practice with it here we go Snow's
up there throw at him stick to the work
once it knows it's him it runs after him
and explode
but of course not all guns and made the
same even standard guns and standard
enemies it's all about where you hit
them so here's a few head shots on this
guy does nothing but we switch to the
thing on his back we can use his element
against him burn so real thought has
gone into these weapons and I absolutely
love it
here's when I got really early on its
some sort of shock weapon but watch this
knocks him back like a shotgun and
there's a chance that they will be
electrified and look what they leave on
the floor and yes it does harm foes when
other enemies see it they will walk
round it how good is that I thought they
were going to be really stupid enemies
and just go straight through it so yeah
so much thought in all these guns and I
adore it because of that I can't wait to
see what weird and wonderful guns y'all
get okay I'm gonna leave it there I have
about five hours of footage and over the
next few months I'm going to repeatedly
put out quite a bit of content for
bottle on three about the guns about
balancing about the abilities I like
this game I would love to cover it on
the channel up until it's released in
September are you with me please let me
know in the comments if you want more of
this less of this I'll always listen and
I'll give you the best I can
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade I hope
you enjoyed this cuz I had so much fun
making it and playing this game
I can't wait for September it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time
you